ja wir fangen direkt an mit einer
breaking news hierbei bild am
montagmittag mit einem unglück im
siebengebirge in der nähe von
königswinter bei bonn das heute früh im
flugzeug abgestürzt ein kleinflugzeug
gegen halb neun soll das passiert sein
die maschine offenbar flugzeug vom typ
piper soll im nebel gegen einen hang
geflogen seien dort und die polizei hat
jetzt gerade bestätigt zwei menschen
seien bei diesem absturz ums leben
gekommen noch ist aber völlig unklar wie
viele menschen da drin saßen in dem
flugzeug die retter suchen gerade an der
unglücksstelle möglichen weiteren opfern
und genau dort ist jetzt unser kollege
tim specks hin geheilt zu dieser
unglücksstelle tim wir sehen dich jetzt
dort welches bild bietet sich dir dort
dann diese absturzstelle
ja hallo hier aus dem siebengebirge hier
haben sich heute morgen eben diese
dramatische szenen abgespielt eine
kleinen flugzeug soll ist die abgestürzt
mit mindestens zwei personen an bord die
sind auch beide offiziell schon tot
gerade eben ist hier der bestatter
angerückt hinter mir da man sich das
vielleicht hinter mir hinter diesem
hügel ist die kleinen kleine maschine
herunter gekommen was genau passiert ist
das wollen wir erfahren von
polizeisprecher robert scholten
erhalten was hat sich hier abgespielt
werden auf dem eingang mehrere hinweise
die uns einen flugzeugabsturz
signalisierten hatten wir die
schwierigkeit dichtem nebel auch
tatsächlich die absturzstelle zu finden
wir haben zwar hier in unmittelbarer
nähe kerosin geruch wahrgenommen und
darüber hinaus das große glück hat dass
eine spaziergängerin uns ob eine
feuerstelle aufmerksam gemacht hat
hierbei handelt es sich tatsächlich um
die absturzstelle wir waren sehr schnell
mit rettungskräften mit notärzten vor
ort konnten aber leider keine person
wäre
weiß man schon genau wo die maschine her
kam und warum sie abgestürzt ist nach
unserem derzeitigen sachstand kamen die
maschine aus angela ganz in der nähe
hier zur ursache des absturzes können
wir nicht sagen mit der unter genau mit
dieser untersuchung ist auch die
zuständige bundesstelle beauftragt die
gleich wie auch am ort eintreffen wird
wir sehen hier viel feuerwehr polizei
ordnungsamt die flugsicherung ist
angekommen was genau das sieht jetzt den
nächsten minuten den nächsten stunden
wir werden zunächst mal die verstorbenen
personen geborgen dann ist das gesamte
trümmerfeld wenn man so will recht groß
mehrere hundert quadratmeter die sind
natürlich gegenstand unserer
ermittlungen und auch der ermittlungen
der flugsicherung stelle wir haben also
viel arbeit das ganze liegt in hanglage
in einem sehr unwegsamen gelände man
muss sehr behutsam vorgehen und das wird
natürlich noch einige zeit in anspruch
nehmen eine letzte frage was weiß man
über die insassen des flugzeugs wir
haben derzeit anhaltspunkte dafür wie um
wen es sich handelt wir haben auch schon
mit angehörigen kontakte bei derzeit
können wir noch keine weiteren angaben
machen
ja und mit diesen dramatischen
schilderungen erstmals zu euch zurück
nach ja danke tim vielleicht noch eine
schnelle nachfrage weil du den
polizeisprecher gerade bei dir hast wir
haben parallel zu euren gespräch auch
die bilder dort aus dem nebel gesehen
also das könnte tatsächlich ja die
unglücksursache gewesen sein dichter
nebel auch bei den rettungsarbeiten den
bergungsarbeiten noch dann haben wir
bilder von dem frack gesehen dass er
folglich völlig völlig zerstört worden
ist das flugzeug wissen sie denn schon
wisst ihr denn schon dass zwei menschen
in dieser maschine saßen oder ist
möglicherweise davon auszugehen dass
noch mehr menschen
zu tode gekommen sind bei diesem
schweren flugzeugunglück ja die frage
reichlich direkt noch einmal an den
herrn schalten wollten wir sprechen das
land von zwei opfern was kann man dazu
sagen gibt es vielleicht sogar noch mehr
tote wir gehen derzeit davon aus dass es
sich hier tatsächlich leider um zwei
verstorbene handelt wir aufgrund der
absturzstelle aufgrund der größe der
maschine gehen wir natürlich auf nummer
sicher wenn man so möchte wir suchen das
ganze areal ab nach unserem
kenntnisstand dem aktuellen
kenntnisstand waren tatsächlich zwei
personen im flugzeug
danke für diese integrationen danke tim
direkt an diese absturzstelle in der
nähe von königswinter wäre es gerade auf
der karte gesehen das ganze als sie
abgespielt heute früh gegen halb neun
dort im siebengebirge danke für dein
reporter einsatz mit ja dieser traurigen
nachricht von heute früh
[Musik]